and I'd like to thank the
Entrepreneurship Center it's a real
privilege to come back to Stanford after
this whole time I was an electrical
engineer I think the year I graduated
was the first year we had computer
science here I also took a lot of
mechanical engineering I have four fun
facts so you can figure out how old I
really am
first I turned in my computer science
homework on a printout so that's a long
time away the build time for my 68000
assembly language class was 20 minutes
for every build until the time we got to
get going the largest major at Stanford
was econ if you can imagine as a long
time ago and here's the kicker there was
a lot of people going to football games
because you could bring a keg in the
Stanford Stadium no longer so that was
quite a time so roblox was really
founded partially because I remember
when I was a kid we used to play outside
we'd roam the neighborhood we'd pretend
were astronauts or army men or whatever
and more and more today kids don't play
this way they're in play groups they're
in organized sports and a lots being
lost kids are losing the ability to make
their own fun to discriminate fantasy
from reality to really learn how to play
beyond the instructions and that's kind
of what we're trying to do roblox is a
platform that allows millions and
millions not just of kids but people all
around the world to play to learn to
create all in user-generated
environments we're kind of like YouTube
except our content is games and our
content allows everyone to play together
I'm going to show you a really quick two
minute video that talks a little about
how we got our start
in 89 with this simple block we
programmed a 2d simulated physics lab
called interactive physics which would
later go on to influence our approach to
building the groundwork for roblox
students around the world used
interactive physics to see how two cars
would crash or to build destructible
houses it was astonishing to see what
these kids and teens were designing and
we wanted to replicate that capability
on a much grander scale so with my
co-founder Eric we began building the
core components that would become the
basis for the imagination platform
roblox soon began to take on a life of
its own we work continuously to get the
platform closer to our ultimate vision
we soon allowed our players to begin
outfitting their avatars with shirts
body colors faces hair head shapes and
more this is a huge hit for our players
to say the least the more features we
added the more we saw our concurrent
player numbers increase since 2006 we've
expanded roblox onto new devices and
hardware ranging from smartphones to VR
we have hundreds of millions of people
playing imagining and building together
and it's growing faster every day
[Music]
so remember the next time you imagine
something no matter how simply you start
there is a universe waiting to be
created roblox
powering imagination so we learned
something really important when we
started off with that interactive
physics software and and what we learned
is that the creations of users in a
community is infinitely more compelling
and engaging than anything we could ever
create and that's kind of stuck with us
so robots is all about platform
principles we don't make the content our
users create the content we don't drive
the monetization our creators drive the
monetization and we don't even really
buy traffic that much our creators
create viral experiences that attract
other people to the platform when we set
out to build roblox we there were some
core principles that we had in mind from
our learnings with interactive physics
the first is we wanted everyone to be
able to play together so at its core
roblox is a social network everyone can
find their friends play with their
friends no matter what device they are
on around the world just as we wanted
every want everything to be user created
in the world we also wanted everyone to
have their own user created avatar and
and people create a big connection with
their avatar so people can put together
any combination of body parts and
clothing and shirts and we have a huge
expansion that's coming on this avatar
system because people really get
connected to it we wanted it to be easy
to make creations and so this had to be
in 3d and behind the scenes roblox runs
on a really deep physics simulation
engine so in the instead of kind of
programming a car if you put some wheels
on axles and put an engine in something
the engine will actually power the
wheels and the car will drive so we try
to power everything from first
principles and then finally we needed
this all to be in the clouds so people
could share their creations
and a huge thing that drives roblox is
is not just playing but showing what
you've created and having other people
build it we're really we run almost
every week essentially an American Idol
for new video game and 3d experience
creators and there's over two million
creators on the platform every month and
they essentially compete to see whose
game can rise to the top of the charts
whose game can get the most favorites
and ultimately now there's a little
competition to see whose game can make
the most money so because of this
behavior we're seeing really immersive
innovative types of gameplay that we'd
never seen before and more and more new
types of games that we're starting to
see in the industry are growing up on
roblox as a giant experiment or a giant
petri dish really the some fun stats as
we've grown some really cool stuff has
happened when we started we were 70%
male and boys that's gone to 50/50 over
time we've really expanded
internationally as we've grown and some
some really cool stats 60 million
monthly players a highlight of that
right now in the United States over 40
percent of all nine through 12 year olds
are playing and learning and creating on
roblox every month so that's that's
getting that's starting to get up there
and the developers stat we're really
proud of is 2 million developers this is
a lot of 9 through 16 year olds who are
interested in making creations on roblox
they're actually learning to write
software as they do it and and creating
a game on roblox involves putting stuff
together and writing little bits of code
so it's kind of learning by doing for
fun rather than because I have to learn
how to code so we're really proud of
that stat the amount of content is
enormous on the platform and we like to
give the example that if you wanted to
find the Taj Mahal you'll find many
copies of the Taj Mahal if you want to
find a Civil War battle simulation
you'll find many copies of that and in
the components that people use to make
their own creations if you if I were to
do a search on pagoda for example I
would find hundreds of pagodas so when
there's this many people making 3d
interactive content get this enormous
long tail of stuff there are educational
simulations on roblox there's a
simulation called bird simulator that
allows you to turn into a bird and hunt
for prey that a lot of teachers are
starting to use in their classroom
there's wacky things that you'd never
think would be fun so one of the top
games is work at a pizza place and
there's really no purpose to the thing
except work at a pizza place so people
go and they choose to be the chef or the
pizza delivery person driving a car or
the person at the checkout counter but
what makes it fun is because you're
doing it with friends rather than joint
doing it competitively and that that
aspect of doing things with friends is
very powerful and potentially more
powerful than just communicating so the
wackiness goes on and another of my
favorite wacky roblox games is called
survive the natural disasters where
literally every three minutes some crazy
new thing happens whether it's a tornado
a hurricane a volcano goes off and our
players kind of like the feeling of
being with their friends and getting a
little scared and trying to figure out
where to run and hide so fun stat there
the the amount of engagement on roblox
is is really incredible it's it's been
relatively constant at about 11 to 12
hours per player per month since we
started and a lot of this is creation
time as well as playtime fun stat here
is the amount of time spent on physical
Lego around the world is 400 hours per
month so we're already getting close to
the 2x Lego time and it's it's partially
because in the digital domain you have
such freedom of expression you can play
with your friends
wherever you are and you you have great
scale in the last year as we started to
accelerate whether it's the AIA you know
app stores Google Play Xbox we started
to go really to the top of the chart so
I've also been really proud of that this
for the business marketing people in the
room we like to talk about our belief
that we have two simultaneous viral
loops running at roblox
we have a traditional content creator
consumer viral loop this is the viral
loop of a YouTube where the more content
the better the platform the better the
platform the more people come the more
people come the more exciting it is to
make content we have that viral loop
except it's not for video it's for
immersive 3d experiences and games but
interestingly enough that powers a
second viral loop which is the Facebook
social graph a viral loop that is
running in real time rather than
asynchronously which is people hanging
out with their friends and when friends
come the platform gets better the better
the platform the more friends come so
we've got this two kind of viral loop
system that has been driving our growth
and and allowed us to grow organically
in a really wonderful fashion ok so when
I talked to the people at Stanford a
couple things they mentioned it'd be fun
to hear some in the trenches stuff like
it's just not all this pretty and bells
and whistles and it's not like just been
smooth sailing the whole time we've been
we launched ten years ago and we've hit
we had several existential moments along
the way and I thought it'd be fun to
share I don't even know if you guys know
about him do you okay so it'll be fun to
share these and and I think a theme from
two of these things that I'm going to
talk about is as an engineer and our
engineering team the reaction is
typically to go hyper detail and to go
hyper fix a lot of little
things which in both of these situations
we tried to do and then as we step back
we saw that a little bit of an outside
of the box thinking something bigger is
what ultimately kind of drove the
conclusion on this so I want to start
with two the first is we we went happily
along for five or six years growing at
50% a year and we kind of thought that
was cool but after a while it just
wasn't cool enough minecraft had come
out the new thing and growth for being a
cool company wasn't 50% it's a hundred
percent for the VCS in the room and so
we kind of you know we had a little bit
of a powwow and we're like how are we
gonna do this and we had a bit of an
engineering answer okay there's we're
gonna do like 20 things and so we're
gonna do all these things and and see
what happens and we started trying a lot
of stuff and you know is this kind of a
tactical thing I'll go through some of
these things you know we'd better polish
we worked on the funnel we analyzed that
we made the product work faster we went
international
we had an Xbox launch we kind of did all
of this stuff then I'd say maybe a year
later after doing all of this stuff we
started to see this happen and this is
what's been happening now for the last
two years which is going into this
hundred percent growth trajectory rather
than 50 percent so then you can imagine
the board meeting okay we did all this
stuff what's the one thing that did this
let's do more of that okay like that's a
pretty logical response so we then spent
we spent a lot of time analyzing all of
this stuff and we've analyzed YouTube
influencers because there's a huge
number of YouTube videos we found that
was actually a lagging indicator not a
leading indicator we analyzed okay we
started making things work faster we put
servers in Germany but
Frankfurt and we saw that turkey went up
in Germany didn't so that that wasn't it
so we've looked at other stuff we just
kept analyzing things our Xbox launch
did that get everyone else playing on
the phone and stuff but that didn't
correlate with the time we looked at our
developer economy that I'm going to tell
you a bit about and we really
supercharged that we started paying our
developers a lot more and I'll go into
that that didn't correlate at all so
what was interesting is we came to the
conclusion that there wasn't any magic
bullet here and what we did come to the
conclusion is we've had a pretty big
strategic vision that strategic vision
over the last five years has drove I
would say seven or eight or nine
strategic things that other competitors
in our space just don't have and what
our belief is is that over the last two
to three years anecdotally what we have
heard in classrooms from sixth grades to
twelfth grade is there's a bit of a
tipping point and our strategic vision
was good enough to get that one player
to play with two players and once there
starts to be three people in a classroom
playing with something you can tip over
if you have a superior product and
that's that's our thesis is good enough
to get to two or three and then enough
to tip over so the takeaway there is is
we're actually pretty glad behind the
scenes of all of this we stuck to our
vision and really the big things that
drove this you can see how our monthly
active users has kind of responded to
that another interesting this is going
way back in roblox history and there's
two curves here one curve is that 50% a
year monthly active users going up
so that's pretty exciting the other
curve is amount of money were earning
per user that unfortunately is going
down at about the same rate so this is a
pretty uncomfortable situation we're
growing everything should be good but
for every 10% we grow we get 10% less
money per person oh my gosh like our
revenues flatlining even though we're
growing this was also somewhat of a
crisis we were trying not to raise a lot
of VC money we you know we wanted to
kind of fund ourselves and so similar
thing here I'm going to show you the
spreadsheet that we worked on this was
our kind of hyper detailed engineering
response and this is okay what are all
the little things did we break something
what can we fix and looking back at this
it's very clear to me that none of these
was gonna come near to solving this
problem and you can also see the column
that many of these we're gonna cause
great damage to the user experience
there's at least a column here that says
fun which okay thank goodness we were
thinking about it and so we started
thinking okay our economy is being
driven by people selling things like
clothing is there a bigger solution that
we can go to and it's set upon us that
we really have to solve this problem in
a big strategic way so we came up with
the idea of our virtual economy we had
already had a virtual currency but what
we were not doing is really
crowdsourcing this and we were not
allowing individual developers in their
games to creatively come up with ways
that people could spend money and the
second we unleash this the creativity we
saw in our community just re kind of
reaffirmed oh my gosh how could we not
have thought of tapping into our
community how could we have made this
of all these things we're gonna do
rather than giving our community the
tools to power monetization so in bird
simulator Oh for ten robux you can
become an eagle instead of a sparrow
about two to three percent of the users
would choose to do that but that's a way
that users can spend virtual currency in
that experience in work at a pizza place
ooh you can buy a scooter and shoot
around instead of driving a car a few of
our users would choose to do that and
what's beautiful about this is it
doesn't impinge on user experience only
about two to three percent of users like
in any freemium product
let's choose to spend money so our
developers now its first and foremost
it's got to be fun and then how do i
feather in the monetization so this
system which allows the developer to
make a game that then brings in virtual
currency and then the developers can
collect that virtual currency and cash
it back out for you real dollars really
transformed our platform in a way we
would never have really imagined and
when we look at what's happened it's
created a whole developer ecosystem an
ecosystem of developers who at one of
our dev conferences are now starting to
make three to four million dollars a
year are starting to create Studios are
getting into groups of five or six or
eight are making companies that run on
top of row blogs so once again the this
strategic solution just blew away our
initial instincts here's a little graph
of our monthly revenue this system we
have found without any additional tuning
has scaled with user growth so whereas
many video game companies have 30% of
the people buying traffic or figuring
out how wait ways to monetize we have no
one doing that and we've seen consistent
revenue per user ever since we launched
the system so the strategic thing kind
of has paid off for us
okay now even to the next level of the
talk I want to relate to experiences
that I was told would be okay to share
like really gritty like what do you do
after college and so I want to circle
way back I just graduated from Stanford
I had a electrical engineering degree I
just wanted to work on all the coolest
stuff I was really excited I was gonna
take over the world I got this great job
at this big hot Silicon Valley company
and so I'm sitting there and about three
months later it's like oh my gosh this
sucks like oh my gosh what am I gonna do
like okay and this isn't really fun and
like I'm not doing it so so the lesson
here
what is is pretty interesting and my
experience was it took me a while to
just decide to go for things that I was
good at and I liked and that kind of
magic combination can you find something
you're good at and you like is really
important and if you find that magic
combination no matter what that is
you'll probably be able to support a
family you'll probably be able to be
really successful you'll probably have a
pretty good time doing it and I want to
just give you a for those of you that
are maybe in this this is a kind of a
rough facsimiles intuitive state at that
big company when I was trying to figure
out what to do with my life and this is
a really bad solution I would say okay
so this is this is 23 year old
engineering solution for what do you do
with your life it wasn't really focused
on what I was good at it wasn't focused
on what I would like and it had this
terrible problem like okay there's like
three solutions what am I going to be a
roller coaster designer and inventor and
educational software developer so I took
a step back and worked at the big job I
had to quit
just too too much of a bummer I then
went to a startup once again had high
hopes within two weeks just oh my gosh
what am I doing here like they don't
know what's going on so had that thing
again you know calling my parents just
like oh my life is ruined you know it's
just like okay I'm 24 now and just like
nothing's happening so it's like all
over so then then I did finally say okay
I gotta take a break and do what I
really want to do and I was naturally
attracted to simulation like physics
simulation I was a good enough
programmer so I went and made this
interactive physics program and really
glad I did it's kind of a risk it took a
while but it's kind of what got me into
simulation and then ultimately led to to
roblox so number one number two is so
that interactive physics company then
was called knowledge revolution
reasonably successful company was
acquired and then it came off to what am
I gonna do next and I took a little time
off and okay I really I really want to
like lead some cool consumer 3d
simulation company so I started thinking
about this thing I wanted to get to and
I said okay I just go find it so I
started looking for this and whoa it's
wow it's kind of hard to be the CEO of
the hottest consumer internet company
when you've just been the CEO of an
educational software company Oh No
oh the kind of company I like doesn't
really exist Oh No
Oh like I haven't been hanging out with
people in this kind of thing oh no so I
started getting this this feeling like I
want to go here
and this is where I want to go but it's
kind of like starting to feel some
blockage here and what am I gonna do so
the same thing I kind of went back to
what do I want to do what I like and me
and a partner we made the decision
to do this which is go hyper risk on
very unorthodox I had been a CEO at the
time and go and get back into coding and
that was kind of the decision but we
kind of made up a little business plan
and I'll show you what we put together
before we started this is from a long
time ago when I was on my vacation from
selling knowledge revolution when we're
starting to plan what roblox might be
you can see how long ago it is because
in the social networking category there
is MySpace and Friendster ok that's a
long time ago you can see that online
you can see social networking is making
200 million dollars a year not whatever
hundred billion dollars a year so but
the idea was there and the idea that we
had is there is going to be this new
emerging category it's going to be
around a mersive 3d and human Co
experience and when we when we talk
about our company today and merge into
two how we position it what I think the
little learning there is we really had
this vision of something big and
strategic and our our vision has
sustained over those 10 years to where
we are today are our belief at roblox is
there is a new emerging category it's 3d
human Co experience for those of you
that have seen ready player one that is
where the category may be in 20 or 30
years for those of you that have seen
the matrix that is maybe fortunately or
unfortunately where the category will be
in 200 or 500 years and we kind of view
our role and maybe a way to think about
our business is we're not really
creating this category we feel that's a
little presumptuous but we do have a bit
of foresight that this category is
coming and we want to Shepherd it in and
treat it respectfully and and be be part
of bringing this
category to the users so so knowing that
this is inexorable and knowing that that
we're playing a role is really a great
way to think about our business the
category borrows a bit from social
networking but what's interesting is in
in the category we imagine it's real
time rather than asynchronous and it's
about doing things with other people it
borrows a bit from gaming and that
there's 3d experiences but we don't make
the games everyone else makes the games
and also a lot of what's happening is
not competitive its social and it boiled
a boy kind of borrows a bit from the toy
space and that there's a lot of
construction going on but we ultimately
believe this is a really exciting new
category and we call it the human Co
experience category a couple closing
thoughts on scaling our organization and
this is how we think about it from our
experience at roblox there's all kinds
of things one can do to motivate people
and to compensate them and get them
organized and to do them what's
interesting is without any direct human
contact we now have 2 million people
using roblox creation tools we have
about 700 who are making a fair amount
of money and we have some that are
teamed up in groups of 5 or 10 who are
making 4 million dollars a year and this
has all happened without us doing
anything it's we've made this platform
we have the right incentives in place
and it's really an amazing lesson for
things to try to do in a company whoa if
we can get these 2 million people to do
this and it's all going in the right
direction without anything can we do the
same thing inside of our companies so we
think in terms of the least bureaucracy
possible we think how our company can be
a set of companies with
in a company our company written now
runs as about 20 separate teams with say
10 to 30 people we call the product and
engineering managers of those teams the
CEOs of those teams and we really think
of can we create a country a company
that's really a collection of CEOs
running their own small company the on
the engineering side we do everything
possible to allow these teams to scale
independently deploy independently do
their own design the more independence
the less kind of horizontal friction and
the more things move vertically and
quickly so I think there's a huge
thought going forward around what is the
leanest set of rules needed and the
leanest set of bureaucracy to create
really big interesting companies that
are very effective so we're interested
in that some key learnings the first
learning we've had on the platform is
that our community is immensely more
powerful than anything we could do and
our community creates better content
than we could create they monetize they
helped us monetize in ways we never
could they attract viral users in ways
we haven't been able to like they do it
their games are fun so it's really
trusting the power of our community the
you know we've we have this vision of
creating this platform where people play
in new and unstructured ways where they
learn together where there's a new
generation of creators and and the
second learning we've really had There
is the responsibility we have with
respect to the platform with 60 million
players the analogy we sometimes use is
when we do something wrong or we have a
bug or something doesn't work well we
can send an individual 13 year old into
a a one-week tailspin like oh my gosh
when we multiply that by 60 million
that's an amazing that's like huge
responsibility so
one of the biggest core values in our
company is respect the user community
because it's it's really an amazing kind
of responsibility for us so I'd like to
thank everyone we have a little time for
Q&A so I'll answer some questions at the
end and appreciate the yeah the question
was being capital efficient is really
important and was how did we do it and
and what was the magic I would say it's
80% intentional and 20% accidental
actually we always we are Revenue
history very early on we started making
money so that was exciting we always
knew that this is gonna be a long kind
of haul so we had a bit of a strategic
vision and we saw a viral traction early
and then I would say along the way
interestingly enough even though this
looks so great there were times when we
would have wanted more money and we
actually found it difficult to raise
that money so there were times when our
access to capital was a little
constrained because our vision just
looks so crazy and like this is never
you know gonna be that bigger amount to
anything
so I think that combination of two
things is really really helpful for us
it made us it gave us the feeling that
every
single person we hired had to be great
you know I'd say very early on we
recognized that high quality people are
amazingly levered so super good and and
you have to finish that off we've gotten
well into the nine-figure revenue
numbers now on about 10 million total
capital so it really paid off for us
charge for certain items which were
these included there's a fine line there
above us you subtract between allowing
them to make minor that also no queuing
in the game too much yeah towards people
that up or - planning maybe changing the
game really so the question is how if
you give developers the freedom to
monetize however they will in game
what's to prevent the whole platform
from collapsing really because everyone
over monetizes and things blow up and
it's not fun anymore
it's it's very early on we stumbled on
the notion that we really need discovery
to be algorithmic and dynamic and the
place where people find games on roblox
very early on we started with what's the
most popular game just updating
constantly we added things like what's
the most favorited game and things like
that and by sorting based on what's the
most popular first and foremost we had
this amazing free market feedback loop
yeah developers knew it was like
touching a hot rail the second they over
monetized their game would get a little
less fun they drift down the rankings
and all of a sudden the system works so
so having feedback loops where we just
don't worry about it and we've seen
instances along the way where developers
have tried to over monetize and try to
figure out their way to get up there but
the system overall is kind of self
corrected in a really wonderful way
question in the bathroom yes I think in
this kind of present moment where
society is kind of living about how
social platforms and social networks
kind of have a responsibility to
regulate speech or to control how you
know users interact to sort of minimize
different kind of social impacts and I'm
wondering sort of what's your take on
that for how you sort of manage the
community in that way yeah this is
tricky I would say for us safety is
really top notch first thing we think
about and so in addition to just how we
manage speech it comes down to how we
computer filter speech how we allow nine
year olds to communicate together what
we filter how we respond how we moderate
that's a really huge part of what we
have to do on the platform there's a
fairly well on the platform stable set
of guidelines we use one of the
guidelines we use kind of at a high
level is if twelve-year-old has their
grandparent looking over their shoulder
is this a conversation that we kind of
pass muster and then once we get into
more detail we we have what is a pretty
consistent set of rules that are our
moderators and our community used when
someone's text is flagged to decide how
we might handle it and there's a fair it
gets kind of complicated so we would
allow a simulation of a civil war battle
we we promise I don't believe we would
allow like a real-life hijacking
simulation so teasing apart you know and
having those guidelines pretty clear and
making them consistent it's worked
pretty well for us we tend not to get
into more of the current stuff that's
about political type speech we try and
have I'd say more of a cross domain set
of rules yeah for the things that you
experimented with in order to expedite
group
but how do you avoid things which for
example what snapchat dish to be added a
new feature in this has a backlash so
how do you consider feature that may
have a backlash in your platform yeah
this is super hard and there's you know
in the whole world of growth right now
there's it's started to have all these
different flavors you know there's
highly optimized a be testing type
growth there's growth where people very
closely watch users and try to stay a
little bit away from that optimization
and just build kind of solid things that
users want and have vision we tend to
have some sets of functionality that we
have hyper strong conviction with and we
just know this is the future and when
when we release those we will sometimes
get enormous backlash but we've learned
over time to stick with our conviction
on those types of features the community
is really kind of interesting in that a
huge part of being a community is being
outspoken and outlandish and hating
stuff and is like we did an experiment
early on when because we launched early
and we wanted to just to see what was
happening
we launched roblox without animation
literally the avatars are like the stick
figures that would float around because
we wanted that feedback a month early so
okay now it's time to launch animation
animated avatars there's no way we're
not gonna have animation so we launched
it there is a bit of a community
backlash if you can believe it
just like roblox is runed I'm quitting
forever you know you've diverted from
your core principles so so I would say
when we have strong conviction we just
go for it like when it goes towards that
that next five to 10-year vision things
that were a little more worried about
like oh my gosh this is the signup flow
we don't have much conviction about the
signup flow we just know we need the
most that will fully rely on the a/b
test so I'd say it's a little bit about
yeah question
China and then come to my vision here
another question that you have your
community and have ecosystem and
millions of people develop there and
meanings hundred minutes people came
there and it's something which making
sense and like adopting things and these
things can create new vision of the
economy system and how to develop but as
personal as you think as centralized
developer platform it think that you can
have a new revolution to cure yourself
quick brings new things all these
things so my question is what do
you think of this doctor things can
never each other yeah so blockchain
there's a lot of buzz right now I think
there's there's lots of people who have
some vision that ultimately there will
be a open source 3d web and it will be
powered by cryptocurrency and I think
this is this this notion is is it's
really big right now there was an
experiment that happened over 20 years
ago or ten years ago VRML for those of
you that have been around that that was
also part of that vision that you know
we're gonna have it just like we have
HTML we're gonna have VRML and we're
gonna have open source web and and for
the record the question is will
blockchain power a more open distributed
type of roblox I I think it's still a
ways off because unlike the kind of the
protocols of the current web running
integrated multiplayer physically
simulated environments it's still pretty
technically complicated so it's I'm not
seeing that kind of thing happen soon I
do think there's going to be some
interesting action around is are there
blockchain currencies that power video
games and you know other other
blockchain there's a lot of companies
being started like we're going to be the
distributed blockchain currency of
Gaming right now I'm not fully bought
into that yet
so I say I say for roblox were we're not
seeing the benefits of that right now
for us
oh yeah way in the back balance
data-driven decision versus the
especially with your design team that
there are creativity which and the
second question order some of the major
bottlenecks that you're experiencing in
growing of business whether it's a
people or infrastructure
yeah so the first is on data versus on
data design and the second is challenges
in growing the company so there's two
sides to this coin and three or four
years ago it was very in vogue maybe
some of the VCS in the room with
familiar with this where we literally
got to the point where we're gonna throw
some stuff up there but then we're just
gonna optimize and sit back and a be
test constantly and great emergent
things are going to emerge we can go all
the way to the other side of the coin
which is there are some companies that
really don't do a/b testing that are
really large consumer companies right
now I would say we're believers in both
we don't believe data and analytics will
drive the topological breakthroughs and
the big strategic stuff it's that's a
long ways off and a huge part of our
product roadmap is is strategic
topological big changes that we're never
going to analyze our way to and that I'd
say we have really serious conviction
that we know when we have this it's
going to be really big that said there's
a whole other place for the use of data
and analytics which is okay how do we
make the existing product run a lot
better and that type of growth data
analysis can be teams that swarm over
the whole product surface don't
necessarily add functionality we just
constantly
tweak that so I think there's room for
both the second question biggest thing
in creating a company the our vision of
our company is in the future as people
start to learn about us less that we're
a UGC platform or less that we've got to
viral loops is we want people to think
were an amazing people organization
we've figured out how to find the best
people we figured out how to with the
least amount of bureaucracy motivate
organic behavior that creates better
product so it's it always comes down to
people and and I'd say half of my job or
more is is the the constant search for
great people to join the company way in
the back yeah so it's kind of
interesting in that Facebook and
YouTube's business model is an
advertising model and an advertising
model brings with it a couple things one
is cookie drops and Coppa issues and the
other is just that constant temptation
to increase monetization by sharing data
what I'm really proud of is our revenues
that were transactional model we you
know we advertise very infrequently now
no probably you know more and more
migrated purely to brand sponsorships
like what we just did with ready player
one which was an enormous success so I
think just at its core we're in a much
better position for the future
besides cookie and Coppa and things like
that we really don't collect personal
information at all for our users we
really don't want to know about them we
just want you know them to know about
their friends maybe but not about us so
so I would say that's that would be our
reaction to
the safety and Coppa issue user has come
back to the fix getting addicted to the
pipe itself one insect a Sunni for the
preseason right now they said they would
have yeah we're here to advocate
parental controls and they have a fairly
deep suite the question is about
parental controls and also question
around limiting users we we do not limit
user time right now
that said the time that our players
spend on roblox tends to be creation
open-ended social as opposed to linear
type gameplay so we're pretty happy
about what people are doing on the
platform on the on the aspect of
parental controls we think it's really
important to give that type of control
and parents on our platform can turn off
chat can turn these things on we do
believe there should be a fair amount of
that stuff yeah question right here so I
like to think that the question is how
do we keep innovation the innovation
cycle in the company ten years later the
the product roadmap we have right now
for the next five years I feel is
actually more aggressive than the one we
had five years ago that kind of took us
through that growth swipe for us it's
about you know imagining what this
category is imagining you know we can
kind of we see it a little bit and we
know how how far away it is like we're
only ten percent of the way there it's
like what are we gonna do next to get
there so so it's you know it's kind of a
system of product roadmapping
we have a lot of people in the company
that are trying to envision what this
category is going to be and and I would
say our challenge is less
putting that roadmap together it's more
of a sort it's more what's the order
like how can we get there what's the
fastest way to get there so it's more of
a sorting challenge yes two more
questions how do you prevent away yeah I
would say the best the question is how
do we prevent users from migrating away
more and more I think we're coming to
the best answer which is how does an
independent studio make a hundred
million dollars on our platform so the
best answer is having the biggest
platform and then you know that's not
really an option the second best answer
is what are the things that bring our
users right now we offer really a lot of
things that no other platform does
there's 60 million users they're playing
across all devices simultaneously phone
tablet computer console VR it's very
easy to get a groundswell of these users
there's automatic scaling so that when a
developer makes a game if it's good
overnight a hundred thousand people can
be playing it all at the same time so
there's you know we've gotten where we
are with I would say a lot of really
good reasons but we do believe
ultimately the best reason will just be
true sighs one more question right here
[Applause]
yeah it's interesting that's the pride
the biggest feet yeah thank you
the question is do we get complaints
from parents because our users are
spending potentially more time on roblox
than YouTube the the primary feedback we
get from parents is oh my gosh thank
goodness my my student became interested
in design or computer science or
business because they wanted to build a
creation on roblox so we get a lot of
that type feedback and then we get a lot
of other feedback from parents all
different things my kids in the hospital
my kids this my kid I didn't used to
have any friends that unlike playing
games my kid has made some social
friends and is is learning kind of how
to act as an ambassador in digital
society so I would say our parental
feedback has been overwhelming positive
Thank You long
[Applause]
you